some good news for women 65 and older
who are diagnosed with small early stage
breast cancer there's a new study that
shows that they don't have to undergo
radiation to improve odds of survival
but Denise Valdez spoke with one expert
who says women should do everything
possible still to put breast cancer
behind them
I think that the author's conclusion
that women 65 and older can forego
radiation is not acceptable Dr Marisa
Weiss is chief medical officer and
founder of breastcancer.org she's
referring to research published recently
in the New England Journal of Medicine
it included more than 1300 women 65 and
older diagnosed with early stage hormone
receptor positive node negative breast
cancer some got radiation and some did
not it showed that adding radiation
dropped the risk of recurrence
substantially tenfold from like 10
basically down to less than one percent
right uh and but that drop in local
recurrence did not translate into living
longer it boils down to living longer
and quality of life now radiation
therapy can cause mild physical and
cosmetic side effects it also requires a
nearly Daily Commitment from one to six
weeks in this study radiation lowered
the risk of recurrence by almost 90
percent at 10 years of follow-up Dr
Weiss feels her patients are willing to
do whatever it takes to put breast
cancer in their rear view mirror I did
everything I could that was reasonable
and effective to lower the risk that
I'll ever see breast cancer again so
although the survival rate was about the
same with or without radiation making it
an optional part of treatment should be
something you discuss very seriously
with your doctor for Buddy check Denise
Valdez eight news now